Traduttore: Eleonora Cavallo
Revisore: Angélica Victoria
(Musica del basso)
(Parla) Prima di tutto
ho inventato me stesso,
l'universo è stato mischiato,
le carte in regola sono state girate.
(Canta) Ho lavorato per 6 giorni di fila,
un inferno.
Finalmente il settimo mi sono riposato.
(Inizia la musica)
Ho creato le stelle, il mondo e la natura;
ho disegnato geografia, montagna, pianura.
Poi la vita cominciando dalla cellula,
poi via dicendo, la capra,
la pecora per tessere la tela.
Ho fatto evolvere la scimmia,
gli ho messo in mano una mela.
(Musica)
Ho catalogato le virtù,
un po' d'intelligenza.
Io l'ho messa anche nell'uomo,
ho creato la scienza.
E lui ha pensato bene
che tutto quanto il Creato
non bastasse a soddisfare
quel desiderio innato
di tendere ahimè al benessere eterno...
...mai appagato.
(Musica)
E così mi ha reinventato
in tutte le salse:
solo, in gruppo, potente o punitore
e dettatore autoreferenziale
con il vecchio supervisore,
con il Nuovo Testamento,
con la barba bianca e lunga
o pelato con il doppio mento.
(Il ritmo aumenta)
Ma sembra che nemmeno
il mio aspetto antropomorfizzato
stia bastando a soddisfare
quel desiderio innato
di tendere ahimè al benessere eterno...
...mai appagato.
(Musica)
E così ha inventato
un po' di cose per autogestirsi;
il cappello, cappuccio,
l'ombrello per coprirsi;
poi la doccia per rinfrescarsi.
Lui ha bucato l'ozono e la sua estinzione
l'ha delegata ai Maya
e alla superstizione;
ha colato il cemento che era armato
poi tante associazioni
che hanno negoziato.
(Musica)
Ha inventato gomma,
bianchetto e cancellino
e continua tutti i giorni a sbagliare,
con la sua grafia da prima elementare
scrive male così
può meglio reinterpretare,
reinterpretare.
Ma sembra che nemmeno questo suo creato
stia bastando a soddisfare
quel desiderio innato
di tendere ahimè al benessere eterno
mai appagato.
(Musica)
(Il ritmo rallenta)
E sembra non gli bastino
le mie indisposizioni;
e lui dall'ottavo giorno
cambia le impostazioni;
e lui prova, sposta tutto,
un lavoro già da tempo terminato.
Ma non ascolta le parole
di un padre che ha tanto amato
(Il ritmo aumenta)
che il bene per un figlio
non è l'eccellenza
ma colmare le lacune dell'inesperienza.
Ed io che sono il padre di me stesso,
io l'ho imparato.
Ma tu non vuoi capire,
della vita innamorato,
e tendi al benessere eterno e appagato
che adesso cerchi una cura
alla mia più grande invenzione.
Ma l'infinito dura tanto
ed è solo frustrazione.
E non esiste cura
alla mia migliore invenzione.
È proprio la mortalità.
(Pianoforte)
(La musica si interrompe) (Applausi)
(Parlato) È proprio la mortalità...
(Pianoforte)
...la giusta guarigione.
(Tutti gli strumenti)
(La musica finisce)
(Applausi)
(Suono di chitarra)
Cantante: La sentite la chitarra?
Pubblico: Sì.
Batterista: Sei tu che sei sordo.
Puoi andare avanti.
Cantante: Vorrei stare qua tutto il giorno
e la notte con voi, ma il tempo fugge.
Se...
Batterista: Hai preso
la nota?...Bene.
Cantante: Se io, se fossi pazzo...
(Inizia la musica)
butterei via tutto anche il cellulare.
Io se fossi pazzo,
non mi farei più rintracciare.
Sarei irreperibile, né qui, né lì, né mai
né dopo, forse, imprevedibile.
Nudo in mezzo alla piazza
senza alcuna inibizione.
Io se fossi pazzo,
avrei perso il senno, le mutande,
ogni valida spiegazione.
Ma grazie a Dio no.
Grazie a Dio, grazie a Dio,
grazie a Dio no.
Ma io se fossi pazzo
che senso avrebbe lavarsi
e conciarsi per la festa.
Una casa non ce l'ho,
il cellulare l'ho buttato,
sono rimasto solo con la mia testa...
vuota,
priva di impegni,
priva di amore, priva di averi,
priva di soldi, priva di tutto.
Ma grazie a Dio no.
Grazie a Dio, grazie a Dio,
grazie a Dio no.
Ma io se fossi pazzo,
io se fossi pazzo,
sarei uno di quei pazzi,
di quei pazzi da legare
quelli che dovrebbero tenere fermo,
chiudere dentro una stanza buia
(Urla) per non farlo scappare!
(Ritmo rallenta)
Io se fossi pazzo mica sarei scemo
cercherei in tutti i modi
di non farmi trovare.
Sì, perché la libertà...
(Sussurra) La libertà...
è fondamentale.
Allora sì, probabilmente
anch'io andrei in centro
in cerca di una camicia
perché essere se stessi è importante,
ma essere sani costa fatica.
Allora sì, probabilmente anch'io
mi farei una famiglia
e penserei solo a loro
perché essere se stessi è onesto,
ma essere sani è un lavoro.
(Ritmo aumenta)
Al lavoro mica ci si mette
la maglietta gialla
anche se è la propria preferita.
Ci si mette sempre la camicia,
sempre la camicia, sempre la camicia,
sempre la camicia,
ogni giorno la camicia,
ogni giorno la camicia.
Ed io che pazzo non sono,
e per pazzo mica voglio passare,
suderò sotto la camicia
(Urla) anche quando vado al mare!
Sempre la camicia! Sempre la camicia!
Ogni giorno la camicia!
Sempre la camicia! Ogni giorno la camicia!
Sempre la camicia! Sempre la camicia!
Per forza la camicia!
(Urla) Di forza la camicia!
(La musica finisce)
(Applausi)
Grazie. Grazie mille.